-My next guest is fresh
off her historic appearance
at the Tokyo Olympics
where she won her sixth
individual gold medal
in swimming.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome Katie Ledecky.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Katie Ledecky ♪
♪ Do it for the win ♪
♪ Her gold medal ♪
♪ 'Cause she knows how to swim ♪
♪ Katie Ledecky ♪
♪ Sure as you can see ♪
♪ After the Olympics
there's time for a trophy ♪
♪ Yeah! ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-That's the applause
you deserve, absolutely.
Well, thank you so much
for coming on.
Look at these medals.
-Yeah.
-Oh, my goodness.
What does it --
What does it feel like 'cause
now this is, what? 10?
-Yeah. Yeah. It's heavy.
-Yeah.
-So I think I need
to give you one.
You wanna wear one?
-Oh, I don't know.
Are you sure? Are you sure?
-What do you guys think? Yeah?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-This is amazing.
Wow. It is heavy.
-It's heavy.
-Wait, but what --
this is like --
can I do this?
-See, that's what we had
to do in Tokyo.
We had to present the medals
to ourselves.
So you're getting
the full experience.
-This feels like I was
in the Olympics.
This is unbelievable.
I've never done this before.
This is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my god.
This is unbelievable.
-Mm-hmm.
-Now, what...
Out of all the medals you've won
do you have a favorite one?
-I really like these.
The front is always the same.
There's the event on the edge
all the time so.
Let's see which event you won,
Jimmy.
-Where is that?
Can you see that?
-You won the 800 meter
freestyle.
-Do you have a close-up?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I didn't know that that's...
[ speaks indistinctly ]
I was wondering.
And then, what this side
is different.
Was this side always the same?
-That side's always the same.
Then the back Tokyo puts
their own little spin on it
so they put Tokyo 2020.
-Holy moley.
-There you go.
-This is an honor to hold this.
Thank you so much.
It's an honor to have you here.
What was it like when
you were there, I mean,
no spectators, no family allowed
to come support you.
What was it like?
-It was a little different.
I'm lucky in that I had
my family there in 2012 and 2016
so I had that experience.
-Sure.
-But we missed an audience
like this, but...
-Of course.
-My teammates were in the stands
cheering, the ones that
weren't racing each session.
And they really brought
some good energy so.
It didn't feel as weird
as I expected.
-Online, I don't know if you
even look at what people say
about you but everyone's
calling you the GOAT of, yeah.
Is it odd to be called that?
-A little, I mean, there are
so many great swimmers
throughout the years.
Of course Michael Phelps
is the GOAT
and I'm just honored
to carry on the legacy
of really great female
swimmers in the US
I don't know. Thanks.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Speaking of Michael Phelps.
-Yes.
-I have a photo here, this is
a picture of 9-year-old
Katie Ledecky with
Michael Phelps.
Take a look at this.
Do you see this?
How cute is that? And did you --
he's just signing a --
was that a poster? Was he in
a band or something?
-Yeah, it was at a swim clinic
so I had actually met him
and gotten his autograph
three years prior,
but I had to go to swim clinic
and get it again, I guess.
-Really?
-And, uh...
He's been such a great friend
over the years.
Six years after that photo,
I was on an Olympic team
with him in London.
He gave me a high-five
right before my race,
which made me flash back
to those moments and --
-That's amazing.
-He was there in Tokyo
supporting us
and cheering us on
which was great.
-I also heard that you were
a big fan of Bruce Springsteen.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I have another photo.
This is you and Bruce.
Now what gold medal did he win?
I don't remember this.
-Oh, that would've been
either the 20 --
-Just rocking? Yeah.
-Yeah, from Rio.
-Did you see his daughter?
-Yes.
She won a silver medal
in Tokyo.
And it's funny because
when I showed him my medals
he said, you know, my daughter
she's an equestrian
and it was really cool because
he was obviously
very proud of his daughter
and I know that she had
Olympic potential so we really
followed her over
the last several years.
And it was really cool to watch
her win a silver medal.
I mean, she's the boss.
-She won the freaking medal.
-Yeah!
-Congratulations.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's amazing.
Okay, I want to ask you
a question that
I don't know if I've seen you
asked this before,
but as a parent, I want to know,
can you eat before
you go in the pool?
Or do you have to wait
30 minutes
or is that real or --
let's get to it.
I want a real fact here.
-I might have some parents
coming after me for this, but...
-Wow!
-I think we can debunk the myth.
You can eat before you swim.
Not -- I wouldn't recommend
you go out and have a huge pizza
with your daughters before
you go for a swim.
But I mean, I eat granola bars
before I swim within,
I don't know, five or 10 minutes
before I race.
-I just hope my dad is watching
'cause this is...
-I drank a chocolate milk
right after I swim.
I sometimes have two races.
In Tokyo, I had two races
about an hour apart
and I was eating and drinking
and my second race
was the 1,500 free so I had to
have something in my stomach to
get me through
a 15 1/2-minute race.
-I can't even tell you
what an honor it is
to have you on the show
and for representing
our country.
You're so cool
and an amazing athlete.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Please come back, will you?
-Thank you, yeah.
-There you are right there,
Olympic champion,
Katie Ledecky, everybody.